ご視聴ありがとうございました
一応豊臣の恋人、驚異的な月の持ち主、千葉県出身
溺れる者は藁を持つかもなどと申しますが
人間困った時の神だのに
必ず何かに頼りたくなるものです
それは恋人であったり宗教であったり人によって様々ですが
ただ一つこれだけは頼ってはいけません
悪魔です
これから悪魔に魂を売り渡してしまった者の末路をご覧に入れましょう
ええええええ
ふっ ついに手に入れたぞ
漫画で覚える黒魔法入門
この本で悪魔を呼び出して 今まで散々僕のことをいじめてきた慎太郎たちに仕返ししてやる
時は来た
今こそ悪魔と血の契約を結ばむ
エロエムエッサイムエロエムエッサイム
エコエコアザラクエコエコアザメラク
ドングリコロコロドンブリコ
来てよ暗黒の神
まさか悪魔
ああああああ
あやたみー
こんばんは
本当の悪魔が来ちゃったよ
何ぶつくさ言ってるだよ
おめえの番だよ
どうも
ハイカブリー
ずがああああああ
ねえリュウちゃん
お茶入れてくれる?
オッケー
ちぇー、通販の黒魔法なんて信用するんじゃなかったよ
なんだ、おめぇ、いまだにそんなもんに手ぇ出してんの?
いるんだよなー
私の恥ずかしい写真売ります!とかっての買っちゃうやつさーん
それ、おめぇだろ
ちっくしょー、今日もついてないなー
本当に悪魔がいるんなら僕にバカごちさせてほしいよ
どうしたトヨタミ
悪魔だよ
何言ってんだよ
頭打ったんでねえかおめえ
しっかりしろよトヨタミ
先生先生
大丈夫か
熱い
おめえ火もろくにつけられねえだか
違うの
普通にひねっただけなのに
なんともないぜ
なんだ
まあどうせトヨタミの部屋だし
燃えたって大したものないから平気だ平気だ
炎のつもりか
まあまあ大事に至らなかったことだし始めようか
あれ? こんな手だったっけ?
よし!
リーチだ!
よし! こっちは三子以降の三色だな!
通せ!
ドン! リーチ一発! ギャンペーコ! ドラ2!
しょうねえ! しょうねえ!
こいつトヨタミにハネマン振ってやんの
あれ俺なんで3ピンなんか切ってんだ
バカだよこんなのウーピン切りに決まったんじゃん
やあみなさんやってまんな
何買ってきたんだそれ
慶応角でちょいちょいっとね
何買って何使うんだよ
師匠知らへんのですか
今時パソコンの一つも持ってへんと社会で通用せえへんで
どうせエッチなゲームしかしねえんだろ
何やって?
普通のゲームかってやりますぜ
結局遊びに使うだけじゃねえか
今日はなんだか手がいいな
あ、師匠、ええ手でんな
お前もうパソコン飽きたのか?
あ、師匠、ポンポン
うるさいな
次にパーソが出たらポンです
わーって言うの
もったいねえ
まだ10分も遊んでへんかったのに
仕方ねえわな
男らしく諦めだな。
ラブ!真逸タイヤを解いたい!
ひどい!さっきコータばっかりやったのに!
うるせえな、おめえも!
俺の方がよっぽどつれえだぞ!
メソメソ泣いてんじゃねえよ!
ほっほっほ、やっとるな。
ああ、師匠。
おや、どうなされた?
コータばかりのパココンが。
形あるものは必ず崩れ、命あるものは必ず死ぬ。諦めなさい。
師匠、ちょっとお茶入れますんで、ピンチお願いします。
おほほ、いいでしょ。
もほ、おや、ほら、ベリグジャのリーチ。
なんだよおっさん、いきなりリーチかよ。
まいったな。
どうした
おっさん
おっさんおっさん
死んでる
どんな手してたんだ
中連邦と
天敗
何つもったんだ
休めだ
引き寄え。しかし、敗漫だ。
な、なにするの?
死んだら負けだ!負けた奴は裸になるんだ!
勝った奴は厚木をするんだ!
よなほか、おのれは!
これでまた豊臣との差が開いちまったぜ。
変だ。羽満に敗満に三敗満と。
僕が上がるその度に、
リエちゃんが火傷して、ケンジンがパソコンを壊し、
そして、師匠が死んだ。
まるで周りの不幸を吸い取って上がり続けてるみたいだ
なんだこのハウマイは
気味悪
まだ2周目だぜ
でもドラの9番は来ないだろうな
詰まっちゃった
しかしまだ3周目
これはバイマンで終わる手じゃない
あった!
人狼とスーアンコ!
悪魔だ、やっぱり悪魔はいたんだ!
はい、もしもし
あ、もしもし、はやみです
え、アキレンじゃ?
豊臣くん、私ね、入院することになっちゃった
え、に、入院?
なんか、腎臓の方がおかしいんですって
精密検査はこれからなんだけど、ちょっと心細くって
ど、どこの病院?何をして?
あ、わかった
あんだ?あの強運の持ち主の早見でも病気になることもあったな
すぐ行くか?
いや、はんちゃん打ち終わってからで大丈夫
来たー!
もし、もし僕がこの手を上がったら今度はアキナちゃんが
あきなちゃん
ほら早く来んなよ
悪魔め今度は
今度はあきなちゃんの命まで奪おうってのが
ひどいひどいよ
やっぱりお前との契約はやめんぼ
ローン
ピンクいつドライチ
メンホンチートイドラドラだよ
そっかー!
結局、大したことなかったみたい。ごめんなさい、心配かけちゃって。
よかった。じゃあ、これ食べられるね。
ほら、これ。面白そうな本、買ってきたよ。
オラの気持ちだよ。
ご、ごめん。お金なくなっちゃって。
バカねトヨタミ君
あなたがお見舞いに来てくれただけで十分嬉しいわ
アキラちゃん
人間には決して足を踏み入れてはならない領域があります
アンバランスゾーン
それはあなたの隣に存在しているかもしれないのです
わいらはどないなるね
失礼しちゃうわ
つかんぽ
なに?彼氏へのプレゼント?
うん、年明けないうちに渡そうと思ってたんだけど
私、とろいからさ
なぬ、言えばいいのに。別に私の買い物なんかに付き合ってくれなくても。
いいって。のりこの顔、久しぶりに見たかったし。
ナヌスタのアキナ!顔色悪いこと!大丈夫?
全然平気。
ちょ、ちょっと!アキナ!
あきなちゃん
あら早かったこと
豊臣くん
大丈夫
さてと優しい王子様も到着したことだし
邪魔者はここら辺で置いてますから
やだ妙な気回すんだからもう
熱はどれくらいあるの
かなりあるな
気持ちいい
薬は?あ、お腹空いてる?
大丈夫。それくらい自分でできるし、寝ていれば治るよ。
ダメ!食べなきゃ薬も飲めないしさ!僕が何か作ってあげるよ!
大した物はできないけどさ。でも、どうしたの?
アキナちゃんが風邪ひくなんて、あ、またゲームで徹夜でもして、体壊したんじゃないの?
トヨタミ君じゃないわよ。
はーい、トヨタミ特製スタミナル丼!
わぁ、ありがとう。
はぁんして。
はぁん。
美味しい?
他に何か欲しいものがあったら、何でも言って。
さぁ、アキナ。遠慮しないで行ってごらん。
私…
何だい?
メロンが食べたい。
Why?
ジーザス!
ダメ?
あ、そうだ!
あるよ、メロン。こないだ、田舎のおがんから送ってきたんだ。
メロン、メロン、メロン、メロン、メロン!
メロン、メロン、メロン!
な、ない!
メロン、ない!
遅かったな、トヨトミ。
何もないんで、冷蔵庫のものをいただいたーだよー。
お前ら、そのメロンは、そのメロンはな!
夕張メロンだっぺ?
違う!いや、確かに夕張メロンだけど、このメロンは違うんだ!
どっちなんだよ。
ダメダメ、こいつ脳みそオプションだから。
-そうなったら勝負だ!-おう!
麻雀の神様、一回だけでいいから僕にトップをください。
勝った暁には、慎太郎たちにメロンを弁償させて、アキナちゃんに持って行きますから。
トヨトミが神頼みとは珍しいね。
だが、貴様の祈りは俺たちには通用しねえぜ。
ラン!
ザンクシワとシワを合わせて幸せ赤ハンミャラパラシータ
ツモ1326
ザンク6400
ツモ単品3色いいペーコー詰め合わせ
オーラストップね
なんだ太みがトップ
そんなバカな
僕が本気を出せばこんなもんです
感じざぼうさ
しかしテンサはそれほどない
まくってやるぜ
リーチ
まずい
シンタロウに4000オール積もられた日には逆転だ
もし僕がメロンを届けられなかったら
アキナちゃんは
アキナちゃんしっかり
ドヤタミ君
私メロンは誰だっか
アキラちゃん!アキラちゃん!
うるせえな。お前の番だよ。
ほら、追っかける位置してやるぞ。
ぼーっとしてねえぜ。
早くしろよな。
ここは勝負せず、ヤスに全てを託そう。それがゲーム回しだ。
裏筋!
よーし、当たれ!
ヤスは様子を見ている。
ああ、泥そば!
今度こそ!
ヤスは様子を見ている
ああ、泥そのもの!
おお、兄ちゃん兄ちゃん!
ヤスは様子を見ている
相撲!4戦ゴール!逆転トップ!
指の節と節を合わせて節合わせ
お前どうなんでしてんだよ!
失礼だよ!シャボだよ!
しかし、場には良い空が見えない。
くっ、こんなでローピー外して、イーシャンデに戻すだろ!
オラの麻雀に後戻りはねえだよ。ただ、前さあ行くだけだ。
ああああ!もうこんな奴に期待したオラがバカなんだ!
やはり、自分以外は全員敵。頼れるのは自分の実力のみだ!
ローン、リーチ、一発、ドラ1、相撲、2戦、4戦、連品、即相撲、2億オール!
来た来た来た!兄ちゃん2回目はオラストップべ!
な、バカな!
仕方ねえ!こうなったらオラの18番を見せてやっべ!
ポンだ!
チーだ!
ドラはスーピー
ヤストは一万九千点差
八千打ち込んでも逃げ切りだ
ならばたとえドラあんこの
リャンスを短期で上がっても
よし
噛んだ
ツモだ
リンシャンタンやお
ドラロクバイマンダ
4千、8千だ!
1000点差のトップだよ。
ここで一句。
ドラの峰を削りし、フヨル殿。
高め積もられ、崖っぷちに立ちぬ。
ジアマリ。
はい、あやみです。
アキナちゃん、助けて。
もう何言ってんのよ。
んー…
もう熱があるんだから、はいっぱい取るだけよ。
ええ、うってよ。
やっぱダメ、あとやって。
ええ?
は、ああ!
メンピン、ドラさん、いいじゃんて。
これなら僕でも大丈夫。
うーん、これは天パイに取らないのな。
あれ?
ツモ切り、ツモ切り、ツモ切り、ツモ切り、
ツモギリツモギリツモギリツモギリツモギリツモギリツモギリツモギリ
なんなんだ、このツボは!
融合!
ちー、あれ?
おー!いい泣き!
ピンフ!リャンペイコ!ツボ!
ドキューン!
やっぱり、ハイファイは僕が取るから、あきなちゃん、ツボやって。
何?
あらら、ちゃんと3色が…
あら?
あららららら!
あららぬらー!
あららぬらぬらぬらぬらぬらー!
あらららららららららららららー!
リーチ!
もったいないや!ウソ出たらただのサウアンコになっちゃう!
いらね。
ローン!リーチ一発、スーアンコを探検!
もったいなくない!
ビンゴがたーーーーー!
あら
なんだか風邪治っちゃったみたい
よかった
ほらほら風邪ひきは寝てなきゃだめよ
はいマフラーして
あきらちゃんこれ
あたたかくして早く治さなきゃね
ありがとう
きゃっ、こっ、こっ
やすー
勝負の筋は悪くとも、恋の筋は外せない
巷に吹き抜ける風はまだまだ冷たくとも
二人の春はすぐそこまで来ているようだった
へぇ、クソクソ!オラはどうなるんだ、オラは!
えぇ!?
みんなで行ったホテルの温水プール
売店には謎の人物
そして、トヨタミくんの拾ったものは?
次回、プールサイドのつかんぽ野郎!
復活!小沢竹書房
きっと見てね!
眠っちゃ、やっ!
ご視聴ありがとうございました
スカット!おたかはいのちがけ!
スカット!スカット!
やりかねば!
だだらららららら!
ご視聴ありがとうございました